it was a win
that unified a divided country we were
united as a
rainbow nation in 1995
one year after the country's first ever
multi-racial elections
south africa hosted and won the rugby
world cup
when the final whistle went and i looked
around the stadium
all different creeds and color people
they were
hugging each other it adds impetus
to our nation building effort
but 25 years later south african rugby
is still embroiled in the politics of
race politics can never be
separated from sport i think we are more
divided
at this stage than we were then
almost 90 percent of south africans are
black or mixed race
yet they remain the minority in the
spring box the national rugby team
in an attempt to get more black players
into the top tier of the game
south africa's government introduced
quotas to force coaches to pick black
players
but it's a controversial strategy
chester williams was one of the first
black players to ever represent the
springboks
definitely quota means to me opportunity
peter de villiers
was south africa's first black coach
i don't think this is your solution
[Music]
both grew up in townships in palm but
they feel very differently about
quotas historically rugby is supposed to
be
played only by white people
[Music]
because of apartheid only the white
people were selected for supreme mock
team
i always wanted to be a springbok myself
chester williams was the only black
player in the famous mandela
1995 world cup winning side
he inspired millions of south africans
all i wanted was the opportunity and
that i can prove to the world
that black people can also play rugby i
represent not only myself but represent
my community i represent black people in
south africa
after retiring in 2000 chester became a
coach
at the university of western cape being
a so-called black or colored
player in south africa was challenging
times
i remember vividly they stopped me from
going to have dinner because
i was the only black eye on the team and
at that time we were not allowed
to dine with the white people securing a
spot on the springbok side wasn't easy
you had to train twice as hard as the
privileged guy because
you have to prove every single time why
you need to be in a team
even though you score more tries than
anyone else
that's why chester believes that quotas
is still needed
to ensure black players get into the
national sport let's go let's go
if you don't have the quota system then
people won't change
and place one comes through the system
and in doing that
we have seen a lot of black kids getting
opportunity to play for the springbok
since the 1995 win the springboks team
has incrementally become more balanced
[Music]
and the springboks selected more black
and mixed race players than ever before
in 2018
but quotas are not always popular in a
recent poll
82 of black south africans said that
players should be picked solely on merit
[Music]
and the perception that so-called quota
players don't deserve to be selected
is damaging while i was playing i mean
people would call me a quota player
it was almost like a smack in your face
that you're not good enough to play
there but you selected only because the
color of your skin
i can assure you we will carry 50
million people
in our hearts as south africa's first
black coach
peter de villier's appointment was mired
in allegations that it was politically
motivated
they couldn't handle that somebody of
color
would be at the helm of rugby they never
thought
that it would happen the last question
of our party was rugby
so they tried to keep the game exclusive
for them
he felt the significance of his
appointment stretched far beyond sport
the overwhelmed responsibility of
getting this job
was born from the fact that we died in
this regina
um one of my friends was shot
next to me during the apartheid years
when we were fighting to
for freedom in the streets and those
things placed a
huge huge portion of pressure on my back
unlike chester peter believes that
quotas are not the way to get south
africa's rugby team
to better reflect the makeup of society
i don't think quotas is your solution
what bothers me a lot about quotas at
this moment
is the fact there's no imperial
no nothing the most ambitious target yet
has been set for 2019 that 50 percent of
springbok players appearing over the
course of the season
are black this includes the world cup
squad when i was a coach i never looked
at quotas i never looked at the race
one thing that was very important for me
was potential
one thing on which chester and peter
both agree
is that the best way to nurture
potential of black players is to do so
within their communities
i believe that we need to start it at a
younger age
it should be done at school level and at
provincial level
to make it easier for coaches to select
those players
i would like to see that coming in the
next 10 years where we say
south africa gets selected only not
because of the color of the skin but
they selected because they're south
africans
they go now to those townships find the
best talent
remove them from that place and put it
in their schools
wouldn't it be better if they upskill
those guys
where they are and at the level playing
field you can see
who really is the best
[Music]
rugby's struggle to transform is seen by
some as a metaphor for disillusionment
among black people who gain political
but not economic freedom after apartheid
i'm still surprised because uh to see
that people are still talking about
craters
because it's 25 years since unification
you know
and in sport we should have gone long
past that
there was no repentance for apartheid
so those who tried to forgive what did
they believe
who did they forgive so this
conversation
for another 25 years was still gone
[Music]
you